pull oh I got it I'll get it okay okay
hey buddy oh my god oh my god
oh dude is jackie chan's Jackie Jackie a
guy named Brad is gonna join them I want
you to kill him all right
don't film me I'm a really really big
user you don't want to mess with me okay
okay my god god I grab the sword grab
the sword he's behind me his name
this is terrifying grab the sword
don't alight let me get the sword at
least let me get the sword okay and I'm
new at this game be nice Saturday's kill
Jackie Chan how did that happen dude
seriously lacking power dude that was
sick bro oh I'm gonna stab in the ass
Katie dude kill it
oh here and I see the battle begins
field wall yeah the Viking oh oh oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah let me oh yes oh
[Music]
okay kicking ah dude someone else join
ok we'll team up against him hey buddy
how you doing
grab it you son of us how do you drop
this on dude he's got a spear oh my got
it I got him I got him [ __ ] not who's
dead now okay
so it begins so it begins
don't come near me
yes the body is mine to feast upon
undies come on man they're feed at
restart
[Music]
at least this one is playable you know
oh [ __ ] get away from me oh I got it
[Music]
where are you come back yes you'll
regret that
take it then take it then come on where
your arms go inside your hey that punch
[Music]
way put that down put that down put that
down
put that down no no no no I dropped it
no no where is it
no no please
[Music]
what please tell Emma behind
[Laughter]
[Music]
I can't reach low enough to the ground
teleports behind you
[Music]
yes undefeated
I just that myself I just stabbed myself
pick up a sword Hey are you kidding me
you didn't die though did you
no can you look at me do I look
ferocious oh man yeah you look good you
look good morning hey hey come on I
can't see anything it's a Sheila's
covering up my screen oh my god it is so
annoying I can't even pick up a weapon
anymore something terrible has happened
at the pinnacle moment I have lost the
ability to play the game it's so oh oh I
got dude I got the power stamps I'm
sorry but you've lost mm-hmm fight me oh
my god what are you doing what happened
to the shield the plan no get your wheel
no I get it I get over game we need a
proper duel and we need it what did you
do with a kitchen knife thing yeah we
need to stop we need a subplot so it was
you we meet again we meet again father
has died and the throne will be mine you
were supposed to bring balance to the
force I hate you
I loved your bread again
you were like a brother to me
I will bring peace to my new empire what
do you guys what do you got what do you
got
I didn't even touch you I'm gonna try to
touch you are you so useless my god you
will be a better King than I this is my
final gift to you can we do one where
you win at least
[Music]
I'll try the ax this time maybe the ax
is the it's why you've been failing
because you've been grabbing the worst
weapons I've killed myself it's why
you've been failing because you've been
grabbing the worst weapons I've killed
myself oh my god oh my god
[Music]
oh oh we have so much Japanese oshikuru
konichiwa cushy catio konichiwa oshikuru
on y'all how she may mashed it dude
when he least expects it hit him with it
oh my wa all right
[Music]
he'll understand what that means okay
I'm going I go for it
he's looking I'm going for it he a Kochi
hey coochie-coochie-coo Shan oh my oh my
mo she is me oh this is me
oh [ __ ] Oh too bad
Xin there ruko she how am i undefeated
at this game I don't understand are you
[Music]
hurry
well not today not so fast
[ __ ] nope this is for all the time look
at IO iron sword I guess I will have to
go full out forgive me master just this
once
[Music]
Wow once again the Viking wing I'm
starting to think I'm invincible or
something